hello everyone and welcome to wild
Chronicles I'm Boyd Matson on location
in Botswana's Okavango Delta there are
more elephants here than there are in
any other country in Africa their
success in surviving the encroachment of
human development is due in part to a
major commitment by the government to
protect its traditional wildlife the
survival of elephants ultimately depends
on people falling in love with them
being willing to spend considerable
amounts of money to see them and take
their picture and for that to happen all
it takes is one magical afternoon like
this for almost an hour
I watched enthralled while four young
males and two older females splashed
around like kids in a backyard swimming
pool you know elephants have all of the
characteristics that we really admire so
they have that playfulness within them
they have a sense of mischief yeah you
know if you see elephants down at the
waterhole flying around you know
swimming around and splashing that's
just what they've been maybe having fun
some of this behavior is typical role
playing for young males according to
National Geographic grantee Caitlin
O'Connell rod will you'll see a lot of
young bulls kind of testing and
experimenting with other young bulls
they'll do what's called a pre mount or
they'll take their trunk coming from the
back of the other bull lying on the top
of their back so that would be called a
pre mount and sometimes even put their
front legs stand up and mount the other
young bull but it's all in play and the
other one will sort of run off and then
they might do it again and they will
just lie in the water and let their
trunk be as sloppy as it possibly can
being just slap it around and block
their whole bodies in their head you can
own this bar
[Music]
the thin a couple of the elephants did
something that neither Kaitlyn nor I had
ever seen before they set upright and
begin slapping the water with their
front legs and splashing themselves the
eternal dilemma finding a way for humans
and animals to coexist maybe one answer
is to throw a few more pool parties like
this one who wouldn't want to be
neighbors with these guys
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium